I think you guys are going to like this
one Donald Trump and everybody around
him are denying knowing this guy left
Parnas and they're all ending up in
pictures with left Parnas that are
leaking very quickly the name Lev Parnas
has become a pretty important name in
the Trump Ukraine fiasco not yet a
household name but maybe soon I'll
remind you the sort of chain of command
Donald Trump hired Rudy Giuliani as his
personal attorney one of the things that
Rudy Giuliani did was get ambassador
Murray Ivanovic quote out of the way for
Donald Trump that's the way Rudy put it
when he was interviewed recently and the
way that Rudy Giuliani partially got
Murray Ivanovitch out of the way was
with the help of two henchmen Lev Parnas
and Igor Froman both have since been
indicted Froman is not visibly
cooperating left Parnas visibly very
much cooperating with documents and
files and recordings and all sorts of
stuff and for a while republicans have
been saying we don't know the guy we
have no idea who this guy is
more recently documents revealed that
left Parnas was involved in putting
physical surveillance on Murray
Ivanovich in Ukraine he did an interview
with Rachel Maddow saying everyone
around Trump knew what it was that was
going on pence everybody knew it was
also confirmed as I told you last week
that despite Devon knew neces denials
Lev Parnas and Devon Nunez did
communicate by phone
Devon noonas miraculously remembering
that last week as left harness released
documents so now everybody around Trump
is panicked and they're immediately
scrambling to save left partner I don't
I don't know the guy no idea who you're
talking about so let's go through it
step by step and dig into the brazen and
bold nature of the lies that they are
telling you here's Donald Trump himself
saying I don't know the guy thank you
question what is your response
your efforts and your frame we're all
about 20/20 you just want to chill by
now I don't know him I don't know
harness other than I guess I had
pictures taken which I do with thousands
of people including people today that I
didn't meet but just met him and as
Trump mentions yes there are pictures
here is a picture of Donald Trump with
left harness back in 2014 and as Donald
Trump says this is not proof that
anything more than a picture with a
random person was taken but it's a
little different than oh do you know
this body shop owner in Missoula no well
here's a picture of you with him when
you went to a rally in Missoula okay
yeah well I met him when swinging
through because it just so happens that
we have another picture with Trump and
Parnas and Parnas with Ivanka and Parnas
with Jared Kushner and partners with
Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway and
Parnas with Vice President Mike Pence
and Parnas with Donald Trump jr. and
Parnas with Eric Trump and on and on and
on but there's even more because it's
not just Trump in multiple pictures with
left Parnas Trump said it's okay for his
own personal lawyer to represent Lev
Parnas and Igor Froman here is an email
which we now have where Donald Trump's
lawyer Jay Sekulow rights to another
Trump lawyer John Dowd and says I spoke
to Trump it's okay for you to represent
Parnas and Froman Trump pictured okay
with shared representation but doesn't
know the guy and of course Parnas was
all over the Trump administration here's
another picture with Donald Trump and
another picture with Parnas I think you
get the idea
Kellyanne Conway then went on CNN and
insisted she doesn't know the guy either
at what left or nurse says and what the
documents show and what the president
asked in the summary well the President
does and not say that he did note that
Cuomo was talking about what left Parnas
said not whether Kellyanne Conway knows
him and she says I don't know him and
here is a picture of Kellyanne with Lev
Parnas vice president Mike Pence ich
doing a similar denial saying I don't
know the guy of course there are
pictures of them together as well but
the real point with pence is that Lev
Parnas is alleging that pence knew what
was being done in Ukraine and whether
Mike Pence does or doesn't know Lev
Parnas is not relevant to whether Mike
Pence knew what was being done with
Ukraine and of course every indication
every allegation is that he did one more
cherry on top here there's been this
very corrupt relationship between Donald
Trump and a woman named Pam Bondi for
many years Pam Bondi is the former
Attorney General of Florida who was
starting to investigate Trump University
that total scam sham money money grab
that donald trump participated in years
ago called Trump University and Pam
Bondi abruptly stopped investigating
Trump University around the same time
that Donald Trump donated $25,000 to her
campaign for re-election Pam Bondi just
so happens has recently joined Donald
Trump's defense team we'll get to more
about that later and here's a picture of
her with Lev Parnas this is the guy who
was managing physical surveillance of a
sitting US ambassador and they all know
him so here's the deal they all know him
to some degree the exact degree is not
really important Lev Parnas is and has
been around Trump and the people around
him for a while he has had access he was
doing insane things as a henchman for
Donald Trump's lawyer the idea that
trumpets are excusing a president having
his personal lawyer through private
investigators put an ambassador under
physical surveillance and they are
saying the real problem here is Joe
Biden and hunter Biden and burries ma is
extraordinarily disturbing now
last sort of word of caution here the
left has to be careful about accepting
everything left Parnas as as if it's
true
left participated a lot of dirty work
for Republicans he's now in huge trouble
he's coming out he's telling the truth
he's copping to tons of misdeeds and
will accept it with a skeptical eye it's
similar to when Michael Cohen turned
Donald Trump and all of a sudden there
were people on the Left who said this
guy everything he's saying can be
trusted 100% no he's in huge trouble and
to some degree he probably realizes the
error of his ways in a sense but these
are individuals who for a very long time
while the going was good they kept on
going with no problem whatsoever so it's
important not to immediately think that
a guy with a life of sketchy behavior is
suddenly our best friend because his
back is up against the wall and he's
lawyered up and he's turning on Donald
Trump I'm sure that much of what left
harness is saying is true but let's not
make him into our hero and hang the case
against Donald Trump strictly on what
left Parnas says this rarely works out
well for anybody including Democrats on
the Left we'll continue talking about
this on Instagram
excuse me follow me there at David
Pakman followed the David Pakman show on
Instagram at David Pakman show
we'll be back right after this short
break